today i'm going to demonstrate a simple
way to patch a lay flat head apart
when a leak occurs the first thing you
should do is identify exactly where the
leak is in the late flat header pipe
if you identify a hole in the lay flat
you will make a cut directly over that
leak point
you will cut it completely in half so
you are working with even edges
we are going to use a coupling or bob
splice fitting to join the two parts
back together
take two clamps and insert them on both
sides of pipe they can go on either way
but we are putting them on so that we
can easily reach to tighten the clamps
insert the bar splice fitting into one
side and then the other
push both sides of the leg flat together
over the fitting
a little vaseline or
vegetable oil will help the lay flat
slide on the feeding
move the pipe clamps just past the barbs
and tighten them with the screwdriver
now the leak is fixed
turn the water on and make sure it
worked
we hope this video was very useful
please check out our video series to
learn all the steps in installing a
simple irrigation system on a small
phone thank you
you